MATTHEW STEPKA:
I'm Matthew Stepka.
I'm head of Social
Impact at Google.
Social Impact is working on
how technology makes society
better.
And in particular, we work
a lot in civic innovation,
working on how we can built
tools for people to better
engage in their
communities, as well as
making cities run better,
operate better with real time
data and open platforms,
everything from transportation
to public health.
Today we have two
authors with us.
We have Stephen Goldsmith who
is the head of Innovations
and American Government at
the Harvard Kennedy School,
as well as Susan Crawford,
who is a visiting
professor at Harvard Law, and
previously a senior leader
in the Obama administration.
They [INAUDIBLE] with
a new book, which is
called-- and I have read
it-- "Responsive Cities."
So please join me
in welcoming them
to have a discussion about
what cities is about.
To be honest, from
my perspective,
cities are the platform for
change and civic innovation.
It's the place where we see
the most courage and the most
activity, both
from the ground up,
as well as from very courageous
mayors around the world.
And at the same time, it's
where we have a very dire need
to make things better.
There's been a great movement--
and we just got off the Code
for America summit
just recently.
There's a lot of enthusiasm
both from youth and young people
of all ages.
And also you have people
from the mayors and leaders
have really showed
a lot of courage
to make these changes happen,
even though they may not
understand technology.
They may be a little
intimidated by the whole thing.
But it makes a bit difference
when they get involved.
And this book does a great
job chronicling this movement,
starting from Boston and the
early days of getting people
involved, by going all
around world actually.
This is becoming a phenomenon.
And I think it's a great read.
It's very interesting.
I'd love to hear more
about your ideas.
STEPHEN GOLDSMITH:
Thanks for joining us.
We're going to use this deck.
We're going to run
through it quickly.
We are rigorously bipartisan.
So Susan worked in
the Obama White House.
I worked in the
Bush White House.
Susan teaches law.
I teach public policy.
When you buy the
book, you'll see
in the back we have exactly
the same number of Republican
and Democrat endorsers
on the back of the book.
We're going to split the
time 50-50 and then Susan--
I get the last rebuttal,
because I'll need it.
So look, let me just talk to you
a little bit about what we're
doing and then go
through the book quickly.
AUDIENCE: You hit
the right arrow.
STEPHEN GOLDSMITH: I assume
it's like this, yeah.
I've been in government
for a long time.
And government doesn't
use its data very well.
But it's beginning to.
So we've looked at
trends in the US
and a little bit
around the country,
trying to figure out what
the future's government is
in this technology revolution.
And I think Susan
and I both believe
that we're on the cusp of
a massive change in the way
government produces
public goods,
and the way it engages
with its community.
So let's run through this really
quickly with some concepts.
You all know all these things.
But this opportunity
for massive change
comes from the confluence
of all these initiatives.
Because from the
city level-- it's
not been that many
years from the time
that city workers carried
paper around in their cars
to the time that they
now carry smart phones.
So the ubiquity of the mobile
devices-- obviously the cloud
computing movement
is relatively new.
But maybe the best way
to think about this--
and you're all in it, so
you may not realize it.
But I was working for Mike
Bloomberg as deputy mayor
one day, and I was responsible,
driving innovation.
So I turned around--
we sat in an open room.
Nobody had any offices.
I turned around to him-- I
got the best innovative idea.
It'll drive the most
change in city government.
He says, what is it?
I said well, just
eliminate paper by the time
you're through being mayor.
And he looks at me like, is
this really the best you can do?
Is this the most creative
thing-- but the whole goal
was to take this inaccessible
amount of information,
generally equated with
running transactions,
and take it into digits, and
the digits into information,
and the information into
changing the way that we
manufacture government.
And so all of these
things are on their way.
So the first thing that,
in terms of breakthroughs
that might be worth
mentioning-- remember,
my perspective is mostly
a government perspective--
is government performance,
generally up till recently,
has been a definition of
how you run faster in place.
So your job in government
is to manufacture
a set of activities.
You produce those activities.
The definition of
performance is you
do more and more
activities, irrespective of
whether those activities
actually produce the results.
And you get caught
up in this treadmill.
And this is just an
example focusing on data.
There's lots of
different examples.
But this is one
from New York City,
from the deputy mayor who was
in charge of this, Linda Gibbs.
And she had an agency
earlier in her career
that was an agency for homeless.
And the way they measured their
efficiency in homeless services
is how many beds they provided
for those who are homeless.
So she walked in
one day and said
how you define public value?
Because that's the
world we're in.
We produce public value.
How do you define
probably value?
And they said our
definition of public value
is the number of homeless
beds that we produce.
And she said no, no.
That's the definition
of failure.
The definition of
success is the number
of people who would be
homeless that we prevent,
as a result of our work.
So now you can think
about this for a second,
particularly in
the world of data
across many different
agencies, and say well this
is a good definition
of public value,
but one that requires
much more data,
like why are some
people homeless?
Which providers work with
which types of homeless Folks
How do we intervene,
and when do we
intervene, with what activities?
And this-- I don't
want to go on and on
about how government operates.
But you can imagine that if
your definition of public value
is preventing
homelessness, and you're
trying to look at what
makes a difference,
that the use of data across the
system, not just the agency,
makes a big difference.
And just other examples--
think about activities.
It used to be, just
a few years ago,
that if you wanted to
improve traffic congestion,
you added highways
or lane miles.
But that's not necessarily
the way to improve congestion.
One way might be to use
the internet of things,
if you will, and
capture, like we
did in New York City, a lot
of data from E-ZPass readers.
And GPS's in taxicabs
automatically connect
that to the traffic signals
and reset the traffic signals,
based on the actual speed
of traffic at that moment.
So instead of the
activity being lane miles,
the public goal is to produce
a smoothness of traffic
and reduction in congestion.
So we begin to think about
how massive amounts of data
dramatically change
the way folks operate.
Now the next step
in that, obviously,
is-- so I've been in
government a long time.
And we used to think that the
way we measured performance
is how many potholes
we filled, how quickly.
So this means that we can fill
the same pothole over and over
again, very, very
quickly, and that
would be an accomplishment.
But what if we could predict
where the pothole would be?
Because there is
an underlying steam
line, or some other problem.
Or in this case--
there's a longer case
behind this in the book--
what if we could actually
predict where the next fire
is going to be-- predict it
from crime reports, and code
enforcement reports, and tax
delinquencies, and
foreclosures of mortgages.
And then we would know.
And we did this experiment.
Many of you know the story of
Mike Flowers in New York City.
We did this in New York City.
It increased by 1,000
times the predictability
of which buildings
are actually going
to burn, inside these tens
of thousands of complaints
that we get.
So now we have a
government that moves
from being reactive
to proactive,
to solving problems
before they occur.
And you begin to get an idea
that the data upon which we sit
provides for an
opportunity for massive,
I mean massive, changes
in the way we do-- just
think 80-20 rules.
Today government manufactures
the exact same widget
for everybody, no matter
whether they need it.
And it doesn't
allocate its resources
in the best possible way.
More stories and we've
chronicled them in the book.
Policing obviously, parole
violations-- even today
in this country there are
probation officers and parole
officers.
They have huge caseloads.
They allocate their time
across these caseloads.
They do very little,
as Philadelphia is now
doing, of using the data to
predict which offenders need
what types of attention,
which offenders
need no attention,
which offenders need
what sort of support services.
And then re-calibrating
the assignment
of the cases, the
provision of the services,
and making a
substantial difference.
And Philadelphia's done this
in a really dramatic way.
It's kind of like homelessness.
How do you make a difference?
How do you calibrate your cases?
How do you spend time
on your outliers?
So one thing that we've done in
the book is looked at big data
predictive analytics inside
the enterprise of government.
But one risk of
this, of course, is
that it makes the-- so the
definition of professionalism
in government is that I get
trained in a very technical set
of skills, inside an agency.
So then I really know
what's in the best
interest of the community.
Now I've got big data.
So now I really know what's in
everybody else's best interest.
I don't have to
listen to them at all.
Well, this is a very narrow
sense of professionalism.
So the next question becomes how
to-- and the one that you all
are engaged in dramatically--
is how does one
use the data that's out
there, the social media
data, the big data, the open
data movement, to connect
citizens to their communities
and vice versa, so we're
socializing the problem
solving and increasing
a new sense of citizenship.
And for that answer I
give you Susan Crawford.
SUSAN CRAWFORD: So this
is a more nascent area
of this development, that
we're seeing the opportunity
using fiber data and algorithms
and sensors to bring citizens
in to the work of government.
The open data movement
has been a big focus
of activities and interests
since the beginning
of talk about new responsive
forms of government.
And something the book
focuses on a great deal
is the power, these days, to
use the massive amounts of data
that Steve's talking
about to make patterns
visual to citizens and make
problems visible to them
in ways that were
impossible before.
So you could
display, on a screen,
where a citizen's input
might be most valuable
and ensure that you're
getting their input in a way
that the government
could then respond to.
Third party use of data and
driving towards useful apps,
using open data, is a pretty
faddish subject at the moment.
But it seems to be
generating great interest,
particularly in places
like Chicago, where they've
opened up enormous
amounts of data,
just starting a few
years ago, and are seeing
their civic hacker community
and startup community
use it extremely
interesting ways.
Same thing's
happened in England.
Not as much as we'd like to see,
so far of third party use that
has big payoffs, in the
terms of commercial payoffs
for those uses.
But something we found
in working on the book
is that open data can
often drive collaboration
inside government,
even more than it
drives for citizen engagement.
But this is a
nascent opportunity
for the use of data.
A story told in the book
that's quite dramatic
is the evolution of the
Citizens Connect app
in Boston, brought about by
the Boston Office of New Urban
Mechanics, where citizens
using a handheld device
were able to essentially
phone in about
problems in their neighborhood
with geolocated pictures.
What we learned in
telling this story
is that citizens felt that
when they were using an app
to report in, they felt
that they were helping.
When they use the
phone line, they
feel like they're complaining.
And this is all so new so far.
We know there's so
many more ways that we
could be engaging with citizens
and collecting data that then
goes directly into a
311, that 311 really
can be a platform for
engagement, in a rich way.
New York is driving
in this direction.
Boston is too.
And obviously, lots of
ways to engage citizens
in creating and using that data.
So it doesn't have to always
be the government that's
producing the
services, but citizens
can be helping to ensure that
their parks and neighborhoods
are safer and more interesting.
And a tremendously
interesting development
is that of using intermediaries
between government and citizens
to ensure that voices are being
amplified in the citizen group
and that government is
capable of listening.
Chicago has a
particularly good example
of this in the Smart
Chicago Collaborative
that has been funded by
foundation support in Chicago
and has a users group ready
to go, testing new apps,
and ensuring that
people in the community
are aware of what the local
government is attempting
to move forward on,
and also serving
as a test bed for new steps
that Chicago City Hall wants
to take.
The Smart Chicago
Collaborative is a model
we believe that could be
echoed across many cities,
in a very useful way, to
amplify voice and serve
as a conduit between
City Hall and citizens.
We don't have
enough of this yet.
But residents forcing
responsiveness using data
seems like a very fruitful area
for development for the future.
In the city the
District of Columbia,
grade.dc.gov is
allowing for feedback
on the grumpy DMV person
at the head of the line,
so that perhaps management
will move that person out
if they're in the wrong
job for their proclivities.
So far limited
engagement in this tool,
but we are looking
forward to more
of these kinds of applications
that take in data from lots
of different directions and feed
it into government services.
Frankly, we see an enormous
community engagement
at the grassroots
level, enormous energy
inside City Hall.
The trick now is to
combine these two pools
and ensure the City
Hall's actually
listening and acting
on what's happening.
There are a lot of hopes
and dreams for this.
But not as much action
as we should be seeing.
The ultimate goal
of all of this is
to create public value
that gives people
a sense that there's good going
on behind the walls of City
Hall and that there's a reason
for them to vote the next time
and for dual engagement
between citizens and City Hall
to produce solutions together.
A renewed sense of
citizenship, more touch
points between citizens and
their government, we think
will create a thick
mesh of civic goods
that are valuable for
everyone concerned.
Because cities, as Matt
said at the outset,
are seeing such
challenges, and seeing
so many people move into them,
and such scarce resources,
that we can only move forward
with citizens and government
working together and
co-producing solutions.
Moving from complaint
center to citizen as partner
is the big shift here.
And again, I think we're
just at the beginning.
And hopes and dreams are strong.
Useful shared
data-- another area
where could be possible
for citizens again,
using 311 as a platform, to
understand where problems are.
And here's a very
important insight.
Showing your work,
as a government,
creates civic trust.
And using 311 is an opportunity
to display what government
is up to and have a
feeling that there's
energy and, from
the citizen side,
real focus on problems
that matter to them.
We think it's a very
encouraging direction.
But in order to act on
the citizen-created data
and the input coming in from
the citizens with voice,
you're going to need
employees within City Hall who
are empowered and have
autonomy and agency.
And to talk about that,
here's Steve again.
When I was deputy
mayor of New York,
we had a 311 reported to me,
an open data reported to me.
And open data was how much
data could you get up,
so that people could
see it, irrespective of
whether the data was
in any usable format
for the average person to be
able to make a difference.
And then the 311,
as Susan mentioned,
was a platform for people--
it was not a platform.
It was a call center
for people to call
to complain about government.
So we got 20 million
calls a year,
probably
disproportionately loaded
by those who have a
strong voice and access.
And then we took this map.
And each yellow dot there
visualizes the number of people
complaining about
something at that spot.
And then we created
the easy to use
interface and trained
the community boards.
And they could drill down
behind these yellow dots
and see all of the detail.
When did the complaint come in?
How long did it take?
What was the complaint about?
And so what happened
then, if you
think about the world in
which you all operate,
there's a mass of information
in these neighborhoods
that's going on via
tweets or social media
or person-to-person
conversations.
And when they could
see these dots,
and they could drill
down into them,
they started to
provide solutions.
Like you know why so
many people, older folks,
were hit or nearly hit
at this intersection?
Well, it was because
your walk signs
are timed wrong, because
there's a pharmacy on one
side of the street and there's
an old folks home on the other.
So people live in neighborhoods.
They don't live in
the vertical agencies
of City Hall or state agencies.
They don't live in the
Transportation Department.
They don't live in
the Parks Department.
They live in these
neighborhoods.
And they see solutions.
So that brings us
to the last point
of the presentation, which
is that-- and I think
the struggle that many of
you will see day-to-day
in your work-- is that
government is not organized
to allow its employees to
exercise their discretion
to solve problems.
The way we've
organized government
is to make sure that we prevent
the abuse of discretion.
And the way we've prevented
the abuse of discretion
is we've prevented
the use of discretion.
So good employees
cannot be good.
Bad employees have a difficult
time being difficult-- I mean,
being bad.
But the really good
employees can't be good.
So how do we give discretion?
And without going--
and here again,
if this building
looks like City Hall,
we've got agencies
going up and down,
so that people are
working vertically.
And then we've got labor
contracts and the like.
And so people are housed
in these little cells.
And they can't get out
to solve the problem.
So we're trying to
look at the use of data
to break through these
barriers, to socialize ideas.
And then one of
the things that was
most interesting about Susan's
presentation and the worksheet
in the book about
Boston is the following.
So we think, those
of us who have
been in public administration,
that you can't give somebody
discretion and hold
them accountable.
Because our government's
organized in these paper-based,
file-driven processes.
So that if you give a person--
let's use a real example.
And I complained to the health
commissioner in New York City
that we were giving ridiculous
infractions to restaurants
for fines for minor things.
I used to gout and meet
with folks in Queens.
I met with two
restaurant owners who
said I've got thousands
of dollars in fines
because my cheese is
three degrees too warm.
So then you go to the health
commissioner and go really,
do we really have to do this?
They were cooking
with their cheese.
It was a warm day.
It was pasteurized
cheese, anyway.
It doesn't make any difference.
And I still remember the
health commissioner going,
well we can't give-- how do we
give that inspector discretion
and not give this
person discretion?
And then what if they
misuse their discretion?
But that's yesterday's format.
Today we know-- they have
smart phones or tablets.
There are GPS.
We know how long they've
been in the restaurant.
We know how many
infractions they've written.
We know who the outliers are
writing too many or too few
or for what type.
And we can hold
people accountable
and give them the
discretion, at the same time.
And this also is
augmented, as you
can tell from San Francisco
with the integration of Yelp
findings with
restaurant findings,
that the information
from the public
tends to hold people
accountable as well.
So we think we can
increase discretion.
We can personalize
the relationship
between citizens and
their government.
And then, just to bring this
to a head, this just basically
is a too complicated slide about
the life of a child welfare
worker, who needs
to make a decision,
doesn't have access
to information.
The information is everywhere.
It's in the community.
It's in the school.
It's in the police department.
It's in the welfare department.
It's in the sibling's school.
And how do we bring
all that together
in a geocoded device
that makes a difference?
Last in the book, and
last comment for today,
is I know many of you
have these great ideas
and then they run up
against government.
And our experience
is that if you really
want to transform
government, you
need to have an innovative
leader, somebody committed
to using data to make a change.
Chicago is a leader.
And many of these offices have
chief innovation officers,
new urban mechanics
offices, somebody
devoted to the enterprise.
Indiana has a data
analytics office
in its performance
office, a great agency led
by the governor in
its O and B office.
And similarly, Boston
here as well, visualized.
The other issue that
Susan showed earlier
is that data badly
visualized is worthless.
Data well visualized
drives action.
This is how Boston visualizes
its performance scorecard.
We recognize there
are lots of obstacles.
There are privacy
obstacles that need
to be addressed
that are legitimate.
There are legal issues
that need to be addressed.
And our view is-- and there's
an imagination problem
inside government.
But leadership can
change all of these.
And then the last
slide is the following.
So we start with a government
that is activity based.
And we're trying to get to a
government that's result based.
And what the data
will allow us to do
is find evidence of what works.
The data will also allow us,
and the social media tools,
to enhance the
voice of those who
don't feel that their
government listens to them,
and who are generally
disrespected.
So communities of
color, communities
that are underserved-- with the
proliferation of smart phones
they can have an active voice.
And we're looking at ways
that data and social media
can produce better voice.
So we have open share data
with officials that listen,
personalized
relationships between you
and your government, empowered
employees, the co-production
of solutions with communities.
All of this is a virtual
cycle-- a virtual circle
that will produce trust as
we become more responsive.
So this is our site.
This is our book.
We're convinced that we're on
the wave of a movement that
is powered in large
part by you all.
And that it's our job to
convince public officials
to use the data
that's out there.
And if they do, massive changes
in the way we deliver services,
increased sense of
responsiveness and trust
in government, which
is badly lacking today.
MALE SPEAKER: Stories
about these leaders
that have transformed
government in a number
of different places.
So if you want to pass
around that mic and people
have questions.
I'll start with one
while that's happening.
Your book is focused on
people and the stories
of these heroes.
Have some sort of
broader numbers
come together about
what's the impact of jobs,
or cost savings.
Googlers-- we're obsessed
about how do you measure it?
What's the data?
What's are the stats so far
on how these initiatives are
transforming government?
STEPHEN GOLDSMITH:
I think it's easier
to measure results
inside an area.
So Philadelphia Parole
Department-- a 35%
increase in parolees,
better results
with the same number
of parole officers,
by using data to triage the
cases and organize what works.
Indiana has picked infant
mortality-- integrate the data,
drive it to the child
welfare workers,
figure out how to prevent it.
They're looking at the causes.
And have already begun to
see reductions in that area.
So it's really not very
difficult to show results
in a particular area.
The problem is evangelizing
that information
to the point where
you actually change
the way government
works, more broadly.
So the fire example
in New York City,
which identified 300 buildings
very likely to burn down,
and we went and
mitigated those 300.
And we either removed
people, added the sprinklers,
stopped the illegal
activities-- pretty definable.
But that was done by a
skunk works, on its own.
So I think the data--
each agency area is good.
SUSAN CRAWFORD: That's right.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So it
seems like this is really
taking off at the city level.
These larger cities are having
a lot of success using big data.
Why don't you think--
at least in my view,
it seems like this isn't taking
off at a federal level yet.
Why do you see less
adoption at a federal level
of the use of big data?
And what can people do to try
to foster that in the future?
STEPHEN GOLDSMITH: Because Susan
left the Obama administration,
probably.
MALE SPEAKER: That's very kind.
SUSAN CRAWFORD: Well
the mayors of cities
are in this position of having
to deliver services every day.
So they see the impact of what
they're up to, constantly.
And they're under real
pressure to do things
on the ground with
fewer resources.
So when someone
walks in and says
I can help you do that with
less money by using data
and target your
resources, there's
an immediate openness to that
at a mayoral level that may not
exist at the federal level.
Because you're so
many levels away
from actual service delivery.
Also, the CIO operations in
each agency of government
are problematic
at the city level.
They're really awful
at the federal level.
And there, they're often just
protecting their machines,
and shielding the
data from being used.
Which really is antithetical
to the kind of innovation
we're talking about.
So it's just harder to do.
There are lots of efforts
at the federal level.
But we're sprinkling
in innovators.
18th and F is like that.
The new Government Digital
Services is doing this.
We're trying to add a
culture of innovation.
It's easier to do this
at the city level.
And it gets harder and
harder as you get bigger.
STEPHEN GOLDSMITH: Just picking
up on a comment from Susan.
So one way to
think about this is
that responsiveness
and trust are
more likely to be
produced when you're
in retail government instead
of wholesale government.
So if you have a
relationship with a customer,
you tend to perform better.
And if you create a
data feedback loop,
where your work is
appreciated, or vice versa
when the transfer of the person
from [INAUDIBLE], that that
makes a difference.
So one of the things we've
been trying to imagine
is that the data movement,
by both increasing voice
and increasing the
connections between workers
and the communities they
serve, will be reinforcing.
And so in the app
that Susan showed,
I don't think they've
turned this on yet.
But you can finish my story,
because you told it to me.
But the idea that the
worker who fills the pothole
can send the picture back to the
person who made the complaint.
That's an exciting thing for
both of those individuals.
SUSAN CRAWFORD:
Yeah, absolutely.
And this then feeds
into all of our themes.
Because then the employee
might have much more discretion
in the field to prioritizes
his work streams.
So he's feeling ebullient
and ready to go.
And the citizen now sees that it
was Al that filled the pothole
and feels a sense of
connection with them.
So these feedback loops we think
will have emergent effects.
And really, complex things
are going to happen.
Because people will
become much more aware
of the personalities and
services in their area.
MALE SPEAKER: And
how many people
are going to be living in cities
over the next 10, 20 years?
SUSAN CRAWFORD:
Almost everybody.
2/3 of all the world's citizens
will be in cities by 2050.
And in 1950, only
1/3 of citizens were.
So it's a big change.
MALE SPEAKER: Do do you
remember a couple years ago when
we had that meeting that you
threw at Harvard that Rajiv
Bhatia was there, who was
our public health open data
guy San Francisco.
He did an amazing job
of bringing information
across agencies together
and created that Sustainable
Communities Index.
So one of the points
is that open data
tends to be across agencies.
It's not siloed.
He got into a lot
of trouble for that.
And in fact, actually
got run out of office.
Because his superiors
realized this
enabled him to
become an activist.
He was able to use
a health marker.
He took transportation data,
and building performance data,
and then give it a good
or bad health rating.
And the health
department said you
can't rate the whole
city based on health.
And he said no, I'm a doctor.
I can.
And he also got in trouble
because when he hooked up
the Yelp data and the
restaurant inspector data,
the restaurant inspectors
didn't like the fact
that all their
behavior was open.
So this points out that it
was a very difficult thing
to accomplish.
And there wasn't a lot in the
governmental structure here
that was really
going to support him.
So your thoughts on that,
and also the role of-- you
talked about an outside
agency, like in Chicago,
it was outside
advocacy for this,
that is not part of the
City Hall mechanism.
STEPHEN GOLDSMITH:
That was 10 questions.
SUSAN CRAWFORD: Right.
STEPHEN GOLDSMITH: At
least 10 questions.
MALE SPEAKER: Well
two things-- one,
people who are actually
trying to bring about change,
often it's a buzz saw.
STEPHEN GOLDSMITH:
No, no, right.
I think the questions
were all good.
So let me decouple
them for a second.
So I think the use of
data is a powerful way
to address social injustice,
and particularly in the it
unevenness of services that
are provided in cities.
So that the power of that
also is the backlash to it
inside City Hall.
And there's no doubt
but that that's true.
But what's interesting about
the Smart Chicago effort
is that since
Chicago's committed
to putting its data all in a
very, very robust open data
platform, if there's an
intermediary, that intermediary
can map where all the
services were going.
I remember one day one when
Mike Bloomberg and City Council
were involved in a huge fight
about which social services got
cut.
And one of the people
in City Hall said,
can you show us the
total number of services
in each community, versus
every other community?
And the answer was well, no.
We can't do that at all.
But we probably could have,
had we thought about it.
So I think there's a
social justice movement.
The other problem--
two other issues
in response to your
question, though.
So that may be helpful
to the mayor who
is interested in that.
It may not be so helpful
to the mayor who's
not interesting in that.
And most people are not
interested in disclosing
their problems.
But the reason that
we've highlighted
a few people in the
book is because they're
committed to the use of data
to change their organizations.
Those people cannot be located
exclusively in the agencies
or they'll get shut down,
like your health example.
But if you're committed
to it at the top,
then I think you can
see it across it.
And that's where I
think the hope is.
SUSAN CRAWFORD: Yeah.
STEPHEN GOLDSMITH: You still
look totally unconvinced.
SUSAN CRAWFORD: You want more?
MALE SPEAKER: Puzzled.
MALE SPEAKER: No, it's-- that
organization in Chicago--
so one way you bring about
change is someone at the top is
committed.
Another is there's
some outside entity
that taking all of
this data actually
just exerts agency on its own--
STEPHEN GOLDSMITH:
Right, or both.
MALE SPEAKER: --and
starts pushing back on it.
SUSAN CRAWFORD: And
so Smart Chicago
did that job of
showing where services
were concentrated in Chicago.
Because the City Hall
didn't want to do it.
They wanted to stay out
of telling that story.
And Smart Chicago did it.
There's very close
collaboration between them.
So they're in such cahoots,
at the moment in Chicago,
that they're not pushing against
what's going on in City Hall.
But they could, in
the future, which
would be interesting,
and valuable.
MALE SPEAKER: So
I had a question
about this notion of-- besides
services and service delivery--
fixing the democracy
model, as well.
So how do we actually
make decisions better?
They're informed by
data and information.
And what's the right
role for technology,
and maybe for Google in
particular, from your opinion,
in that situation?
SUSAN CRAWFORD: Never to
allow a policy decision
to be made without
data, to visualize
that data to ensure that the
decision makers are actually
fact driven.
We've got a problem in that
many major decisions are
made by five guys in a room
after a lot of public comment.
But the public comment isn't
quantified, isn't understood.
Even taking our
regulatory structure
and parsing through who
said what about what
and how that links to
what the decisions are,
we can't even do that.
So we're at a very early stage.
Google could help dramatically
with a standard for rule making
across agencies,
at the city level
and at federal level,
could help with standards
for visualization,
and encourage people
to have-- inside every
rule-making agency--
to be able to work with data.
We've got a lot of data literacy
going on inside agencies
as well.
So you guys can do a
tremendous amount, actually,
to make things more data driven.
We really are not there,
at the moment, in my view.
STEPHEN GOLDSMITH: I
was trying to figure out
how to get more community
input for proposed regulations.
And the federal
agencies and many states
put their proposed
rules up online.
But what happens is the
rules are done by the time
they ask for community feedback.
It's like suddenly you want
do [INAUDIBLE] at a community
meeting and people yell
at you for four hours.
Then you go do what you
would have done anyway, just
like an experience.
So the question
then becomes how do
you take the problem
you're trying
to solve, before
you have configured
the professional
solution, and socialize
the problem with the question.
And that, in large
part, depends on how
you express and
visualize the question,
and then sort the
response, as part
of a true democratic
process that
then informs the bureaucracy.
And I think that
what we've done is
we've left so much social media
information on the table that
could inform those decisions.
But then just last, it's
really, truly iterative.
I want to-- this is a
story from many years.
When I first got elected
mayor, I went to an opening--
this will just take
a second-- but I
went to an opening of a park
that my predecessor had done.
I cut the ribbon,
because I'm a politician.
So it was cut on mine--
so I went out there.
And everybody was mad.
And I said you got a new park.
Why are you mad?
And they said because old folks
live on this side of the park.
And you got the
basketball courts at night
on their side of the park.
And you could have put it on
the other side of the park.
And you designed this park.
So then I said I'm doing
this all differently.
I raised a lot of money.
I'm going to redo your parks.
And I went to a meeting.
And I had the first meeting.
And I said I'm going
to redo your park.
What do you want there?
And they went and looked at me
like, we're not park planners.
What do you expect us to say?
So the answer was we had to
configure a set of options,
visualize those options, ask
for the input in a sincere way,
then form-- and so I think
that iterative process, using
social media, may be the
way to think about it.
MALE SPEAKER: So there
are 12 ballot initiatives
on the SF ballot this November.
And two of them
apparently concern
whether soccer fields
should have artificial turf
or not in certain
parts of the city.
That's one example of a
responsive democratic process
going somewhat astray, arguably.
And maybe there are
bigger questions
that we should be
debating as a city that
go beyond soccer field surfaces.
So how do you build
in that mechanism
for channeling real concerns
that citizens actually
have into the democratic
evaluation process?
STEPHEN GOLDSMITH: I don't
even know what to say.
Well, I'll give an answer.
But I think actually
your question is worth
a lot of thought-- more thought.
I envision a situation
where the responsiveness
is microtargeted, where
it's got two definitions.
One is you register
for the information
you want personally
from your city,
so you're getting that without
having to bang on the city.
The second is that
your community now
has enough information and
it gets questions in advance
about OK, we got money
to do your sidewalks.
Which sidewalks do
you want done first?
What improvements do
you want in your area?
And then you share that
with your neighbors.
And so I'm envisioning that, if
we can be more response-- one
other issue.
Prior to all this
information, it really
was very difficult
for a bureaucrat
to actively engage
a large community.
There's only so many people.
The people who come
to the meetings
are not necessary
the right people.
All they do is yell and
they show off to each other.
That's an off the
record kind of comment.
They're all-- it's
a performance art.
It's really not an engagement.
So the extent to
which we can deepen
that, socializing
those problems,
we ought to be at least able
to defuse some of those-- I
have to resort to an
initiative to get the attention
about the artificiality
of my soccer fields.
MALE SPEAKER: Do you think
then this responsive city
leads to less yelling
at those town meetings?
Or does it change the
dynamics of political debate
in some way?
SUSAN CRAWFORD: Well,
here's something
I know to be true, that when you
put a shared screen up in front
of a group of people who
otherwise might be yelling
at each other, the emotional
heat really goes down.
And I've seen this over
and over and over again.
And where that shared
screen has data on it
that people have already
agreed is relevant and true,
then you get them
in fact-finding
and problem-solving mode--
problem solving mode.
They think of
themselves as a team,
coming from different
constituencies.
So to the extent that
big data visualized well,
plus stakeholder
engagement that's genuine,
where they are confident that
the decision maker is going
to respond, I think there's
a lot of responsiveness
that's possible there.
But you still want to give
people the channel to yell,
if they want to.
MALE SPEAKER: It's politics.
SUSAN CRAWFORD: But this is
an additional channel that
is problem solving,
joint problem solving.
MALE SPEAKER: So we talked
a lot about big data
and digital technology,
and I think--
and all the great
outcomes that can produce.
And one of the
questions that I ask
is as we move toward
digitizing services,
do we run the risk
of exacerbating
the digital divide or
increasing inequality?
And given your
experience, I'm just
wondering how do you think
through that problem?
And what we do to
mitigate against that?
SUSAN CRAWFORD: Well,
I'd take it as a given
that the responsive
city only functions
when there is ubiquitous
access that's cheap,
and people don't have to think
about the latency-- anything.
It should just be in the air.
So for me, fiber is
at the bottom of this,
and ensuring that every
city has competitive, cheap,
connectivity is essential.
STEPHEN GOLDSMITH: This is a
totally unsolicited endorsement
of Google Fiber.
SUSAN CRAWFORD: Right,
exactly, exactly.
But where we really
need help though
is in literacy
efforts, where people
don't feel embarrassed
or ashamed or afraid
to use these tools.
And there we're at
a terrible deficit.
So access alone isn't enough.
We've got to help people
become conversant with it.
This should be part of the
elementary school curriculum.
You're in there,
using the tools.
STEPHEN GOLDSMITH: So I
actually agree with Susan.
But I actually think the
answer is emphatically
the opposite of the
implication in the question.
It's a friendly response.
So government doesn't fairly
distribute its resources today.
And years ago, I used to be in
the-- as a district attorney,
I used to be in the child
support enforcement business.
This was a long time.
And two experiences are still
sharp in my mind in response
to your question.
One was that we started out
just representing welfare moms.
Because that was
the federal law.
And they got OK services.
Then the law expanded for us
to represent middle class moms.
And the noise level from
the quality of our services
went up dramatically.
They knew how to get to us.
They knew who to call.
They knew how to articulate.
They knew how to get attention.
So it's not like in a
pre-internet, digital divide
world that resources
are even to begin with.
Secondly if we think
smart devices--
if we think about the
ubiquity of smart devices,
I think that we can move to
more equitable distribution
of resources, where
we give people voice.
Or maybe they don't
even have to be smart.
Maybe they could just be SMSing
us through their old phones.
But they can have
a voice that we
can listen to and
pay attention to.
And then if we add
a few other things,
like rate your public
employee, text back whether
they're-- then I think we
can begin to equate it.
So it's just a
long way of saying
I think the system
is imbalanced today.
I bet of the 20 million phone
calls I got in New York City,
as deputy mayor in
our call center,
they couldn't have been
equally distributed
across ethnic groups.
They had to be totally
to the people who
knew how to call,
complain in English.
MALE SPEAKER: So more peaceful
debate, maybe more equality,
delivery of services.
SUSAN CRAWFORD: Or maybe not.
It's a compared to what.
MALE SPEAKER: They're at
least that supposition.
What problem can't this solve?
And I ask that not
because you're saying
this is a silver bullet.
But just thinking
honestly, whenever
you're trying to solve a hard
problem, you want to see well,
what can't we take on?
What do we have
to do in parallel?
STEPHEN GOLDSMITH: Well, Susan
can tell you what we can't do.
I'll make one more comment
about what we can do.
MALE SPEAKER: Are you
the politician or is she?
STEPHEN GOLDSMITH:
I'm a politician.
She's a statesman.
So look, I've got
$5,000 to spend.
And I can spend it
equally distributed over
a set of identical widgets.
Or I can look at outliers
and pay attention
to which restaurant is
most likely to poison you
with their bacteria and which
ones have never done that.
Which builder is going
to build a bad house?
What landlord's
going to do this?
Where are you most likely
to have a health outbreak?
I can reorganize the
distribution of public services
in a dramatic way that
makes me both responsive
and more effective.
And that's all data driven.
And we could never
do that before.
So I think that the data
revolution has massive effect.
MALE SPEAKER: Sky's the limit.
STEPHEN GOLDSMITH:
It's unlimited.
SUSAN CRAWFORD: Yeah, right.
MALE SPEAKER: OK,
Susan, you want
to leave us with the last thing
before I see somebody looking
in at us and [INAUDIBLE]
to kick us out?
SUSAN CRAWFORD:
Well, you can just
tell that Steve Goldsmith
was a great mayor.
And there's no substitute
for a visionary mayor who
can convince his
citizens that tomorrow's
going to be better
than yesterday.
No data is going to do that.
That personality is
extremely important.
And also humans
aren't going away.
And they are not going
to be supplanted.
You're still going to need the
responsiveness of policy that's
not created
automatically by data.
It doesn't arise by magic.
So all the wise decisions
about allocations
of resources,
priorities for a city,
how the city's going
to position itself
in the global marketplace, that
doesn't happen through data
alone.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, on that
note, thank our speakers.
SUSAN CRAWFORD: OK.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank
you guys for coming.
SUSAN CRAWFORD: Thank you.
Oh, books.
[APPLAUSE]